now I want to show you video of one of
the guys who has since suspended his
name is Justin Pearson
at the Capitol this is a day or two ago
take a look
seemed like the NRA in gun lobbyists
might win
but oh that was good news for us I don't
know how long this Saturday in the state
of Tennessee might last but oh we have
good news folks we've got good news that
Sunday always comes well that's that's
pretty powerful he's got the hair and
the thin tie and he's got the MLK accent
that's powerful stuff that feels very
authentic doesn't it
hot damn here he is same guy 2016.
hey Pearson and I'm running for
president of BSG there are a few reasons
that we're running this campaign this
year one has to do with representation
how can we represent all voices in a
conversation I want to do this by
partnering with organizations from the
booty Democrats to the Boon Republicans
I want to bring together different
voices dissenting voices voices that may
be more liberal or more conservative in
order that we can reach a point of sort
of the radical middle
foreign
that was him as a normal person speaking
in normal Cadence back in 2016. let's
just watch five or ten more seconds of
him just a couple days ago
seemed like the NRA and gun lobbyists
might win
but oh that was good news for us I don't
know how long this Saturday in the state
of Tennessee might last you know I'm
starting to think that anyone can do an
accent like that and I don't know how
long I can do the accent for but I'll do
it as long as I have to to drive home
the point that anyone can talk in a
certain way and I can lift a coffin mug
and talk over here even though I'm
talking to nobody and I can take out my
ChapStick and I can put it on and tell
everybody from sea to shine and see that
if you just use this accent then gosh
Dawn it you're making a better point
because if you talk like this and I want
to bring the Democrats and the
Republicans together that doesn't really
work you understand you've got to grow
out the hair you've got to tell the
people what your problem is and you've
got to get the media to tell everybody
that your mlk2 because this kid over
here he was just saying hey Republicans
and Democrats maybe we can find some
things together but it doesn't work to
do with that away
[Music]